wenn Lioba wichl ihre Wäsche macht
achtet sie genau darauf dass Sie nicht
zu viel Energie verbraucht die Rentnerin
ist 81 Jahre alt lebt in einer
Einzimmerwohnung in München sie muss
Strom sparen
also Kochwäsche gibt es nicht mehr die
mache ich schon lange nicht mehr ich war
höchsten 60 Grad aber solche Sachen
sonst nur 30
günstiger ist
machen wie sie dadurch den Winter kommen
wenn sie mehr für Strom zahlen müssen ja
weil ich ja ab und zu noch mit meinen
heizofer nachheizen muss weil das Bad
lässt sich so schwer verheizen da muss
ich elektrisch nachheizen und das wird
teuer
Lioba Bichl bekommt
1188 Euro Rente im Monat davon muss die
Miete zahlen Nebenkosten und Heizung
weniger als 400 Euro bleiben übrig für
lebensmittelkleidung und eben auch Strom
ihren monatlichen Abschlag hat die
Rentnerin jetzt freiwillig erhöht von 33
auf 45 Euro
ich habe wirklich Angst dass ich das
nicht mehr schaffe
meine kann mich ja nicht den ganzen
Winter in die dunkle Bude reinsetzen es
scheint ja nicht jeden Tag die Sonne
was soll man da machen
die Seniorenhilfe Lichtblick in München
hier kann Lioba Wichtel auf
Unterstützung zählen 43 Jahre hat sie
als Friseurin gearbeitet und jetzt
reicht es kaum zum Leben
ich habe kein Geld mehr für Lebensmittel
für Lebensmittel okay dann schauen wir
mal dass ich ihnen Lidl Gutscheine gebe
ja die 81-Jährige ist auf Gutscheine von
privaten Spendern angewiesen
Sozialleistungen bekommt sie nicht
drei Lidl Gutscheine damit sie jetzt
bisschen dann auch Vorrat kaufen können
es wird alles teurer und jetzt kriege
ich wahrscheinlich auch noch meine
Stromabrechnung so wie Lioba Bichl sind
Millionen Deutsche verunsichert denn
seit dem Krieg gegen die Ukraine sind
die Strompreise an der Börse extrem
gestiegen im Januar 2021 kostete die
Megawattstunde noch 60 Euro mittlerweile
sind es mehr als 400 Euro fast 7 mal so
viel Strom ist deshalb so teuer weil er
auch aus Gas produziert wird insofern
gibt es eine Verbindung zwischen der
Gaskrise und den drastisch gestiegenen
Strompreisen die Regel ist dass der
Preis bestimmt wird von den Kosten des
teuersten noch benötigten Produzenten im
Fall von Strom ist es heute so dass es
oft Gaskraftwerke sind die die teuersten
Kraftwerke sind die man gerade noch
braucht um die Nachfrage nach Strom zu
decken ein anderer wichtiger Grund für
die hohen Strompreise liegt bei unserem
Nachbarn Frankreichs Atomkraftwerke
Probleme viele Reaktoren sind
abgeschaltet weil sie gewartet werden
oder wegen der niedrigen Wasserstände in
den Flüssen nicht richtig gekühlt werden
können
frankreich hat 18 Atomkraftwerke mit
insgesamt 56 Reaktoren davon sind
zurzeit nur die Hälfte am Netz gerade
einmal 28
frankreich hat traditionell immer sehr
viel Strom exportiert und jetzt
exportieren Sie einfach nicht mehr so
viel das hat den Effekt dass sozusagen
rundherum weniger günstiger
französischer Strom verfügbar ist und
die Preise überall in Europa deswegen
steigen
frankreich muss sogar Strom importieren
allein Deutschland hat 2022 bereits 5000
Gigawattstunden geliefert ein neuer
Rekordwert und das Jahr ist noch nicht
um
wir fahren nach Frankreich mit der Bahn
über den Rhein
in diesem Vorort von Straßburg verdienen
die Menschen nicht viel
Durchschnittseinkommen 600 Euro im
Sozialzentrum suchen immer mehr
bedürftige Hilfe
für die Leute sind die Rechnungen schon
jetzt sehr hoch mit unter höher als ihr
Einkommen das geht schon seit einigen
Jahren so weil die Gebäude hier im
Viertel sehr sehr schlecht isoliert sind
im Viertel wohnt auch Leila benici sie
ist gegen Atomkraft und macht sich
Sorgen wie Sie Ihre Stromrechnung zahlen
soll
[Musik]
Kaffee sind inzwischen zum Luxus
geworden ich weiß nicht wie ich mit den
Preissteigerungen für Energie diesen
Winter klarkommen werde
dabei hat die französische Regierung die
Strompreise gedeckelt nur 4% Erhöhung
sind erlaubt Leila benici versucht
trotzdem Strom zu sparen wo sie nur kann
wie lange die Hilfe reicht weiß niemand
ob die Regierung den preisdeckel
beibehalten wird um uns zu beschützen da
habe ich meine Zweifel wie die meisten
Bürger Frankreichs mache ich mir Sorgen
und frage mich was die Zukunft so bringt
ganz Europa leidet unter hohen
Energiepreisen in Brüssel soll nun eine
Lösung gefunden werden der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister mit einem
Versprechen
die Botschaft ist völlig klar wir müssen
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
Unternehmen in Europa entlasten das
Teilen alle Minister das war völlig
übereinstimmte festgestellt und auch die
entlastungswege sind klar wir müssen die
Preise runterbringen doch wie das
gelingen soll darüber wird in
Deutschland heftig gestritten vor allem
über die Rolle der letzten drei
Atomkraftwerke Habeck will zwei
Reaktoren als Reserve vorhalten aber
grundsätzlich am Atomausstieg festhalten
ein Kompromiss zwischen partei-resort
und energiepolitischer Vernunft so ein
immense Spannungsverhältnis er hat
einerseits eine Partei im Rücken die im
Grunde ihn drängt das jetzt tatsächlich
umzusetzen diesen kompletten Ausstieg
aus der Kernenergie gleichzeitig hat er
eine Öffentlichkeit hat er
Wirtschaftsunternehmen die sich Sorgen
machen dass unter Umständen auch der
Strom ausgehen könnte die Angst geht um
nicht nur vor hohen Preisen sondern auch
vor Blackout die Stromnetzbetreiber
haben in einem Stresstest berechnet
bleibt französischer Atomstrom weiter
aus und kommt ein harter Winter dann
wird es eng in solch einem Szenario
sollte Deutschland nicht auf seine
letzten Atommeiler verzichten sagen die
Netzbetreiber ein Baustein dieses
Szenarios können die Atomkraftwerke sein
das klar wir haben natürlich ein
Interesse daran dass wir
frühzeitig Klarheit haben mit welchen
dieser Bausteine wir für den kommenden
winterplanen können aber der Minister
hat dargestellt dass er die Option offen
halten will und das nehmen wir jetzt zur
Kenntnis
Habeck will warten erst im Dezember
entscheiden
die Union setzt den Minister unter Druck
obwohl CDU und CSU den Atomausstieg
beschlossen haben wollen sie nun längere
Laufzeiten und versprechen dass dadurch
die Strompreise sinken Familien
Handwerker Pflegeheime haben jeden Tag
Stresstest seit Monaten die können
nämlich ihre Stromrechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen und Stromrechnung Strompreise
sind deswegen hoch weil das Angebot in
Europa zu niedrig ist und das heißt
jedes Kraftwerk muss ans Netz doch viele
Energieexperten sagen dass die letzten
deutschen Reaktoren nicht dafür
ausgerüstet sind um so viel Strom zu
produzieren dass der Preis spürbar sinkt
viel Wumms hätten die Kernkraftwerke
dann gehabt wenn man dafür gesorgt hätte
dass sie noch ein zwei drei Jahre unter
Vollbetrieb laufen hätten können und
dafür hätte man sicher im im Frühling
oder im Sommer neue Brennstäbe bestellen
müssen mein meine Einschätzung ist dass
der Zug der abgefahren ist
Lioba Bichl ist es egal wo ihr Strom
herkommt sie muss in sich nur leisten
können die Rentnerin bekommt zwar eine
Einmalzahlung von 300 Euro aber ob das
für den Winter reichen wird weiß sie
noch nicht
es macht mir schlaflose Nächte diese
ganze Situation überhaupt
das ist ja nicht bloß der Strom es ist
kommen ja die Heizkosten dazu und so
lang lebe ich nimmer
ich weiß es nicht mir tun die jungen
Leid ganz ehrlich die jungen Leute tun
mir leid die wachsen in der Zukunft drin
keine Ahnung was diesmal wird